das hier ist das für mich perfekte
Spiegelei es ist unten schön knusprig
das Eiweiß ist nicht mehr glibbrig und
vor allem ist das Eigelb noch schön
flüssig so muss Spiegelei sein und dabei
ist es ganz egal welche Pfanne wir
benutzen ob es Gusseisen beschichtet
oder unbeschichtet ist wir brauchen
einfach nur Öl und Eier Öl damit es
schön knusprig wird Eier weil wir halt
Spiegeleier machen ich gebe in alle
Pfannen ordentlichen Schluck Öl nur so
kann das Ei von unten schön knusprig
werden und dann können es eigentlich
kaum einfacher sein Ei aufschlagen
wichtig ist dass die Pfanne schön heiß
ist und dann einfach hineingeben das
sind die Geräusche die ich hören will
wir sehen jetzt schon richtig schön dass
ich diese kleinen Bläschen bilden und
das gute ist wir benutzen keinen Deckel
wir lassen das Ei von unten herauf
durchgaren was nicht fehlen darf sind
Salz und Pfeffer und ganz egal in
welcher Pfanne es klebt nicht an es
funktioniert in allen Pfannen aber ich
muss fast sagen in der Edelstahlpfanne
sieht's fast am besten aus also diese
wunderschönen knusprigen Ränder oben
drauf das Eigelb ist noch komplett runny
ist schon sexy